everybody does palettes now palettes are
all the rage
let's serve up some news sunny cider
also making headlines is revolution
beauty's friends
2.0 collection i know you're going to
love this one these are
shades lip glosses body scrubs based on
the looks of the iconic show so we're
talking
lip boss's name chandler joey ross we've
got a
i mean there's so you've got the like
iconic door
but they also have a central perk coffee
cup which is reusable
and it's got a scrub in it as well that
one i do want oh
i love a good scrub nylon magazine
reports that the game's latest update
finally allows players to give their
avatars natural textured hair and it
makes a big difference
to players of color who might want to
their mini me to have locks or
an afro adorable hair puffs and earlier
this year animal crossing made all skin
types feel welcomed by letting players
customize their avatars with vitiligo
acne
psoriasis i mean amazing
such a genius idea and it's about time
they reframed all these conversations
yeah
that are you know notoriously negative
to something positive and celebratory
your neighborhood target store might
have a starbucks in it
but it's all about to get a little more
company target just announced
that next year it's installing ulta
shops inside
100 of their stores of which there are
1800
with hope to expand also is also
training target employees
in beauty consulting to staff these
shops in a shop
this is not good news in the fact that i
did not need
any more excuses to spend any more time
in target
i'm not just one card there's gonna be
two cards maybe three cards following me
around
it's like what are you doing today going
to one place one place
speaking of vogue they report that
gender lines are disappearing in the
beauty space too
and the beauty industry is valued at 532
billion dollars globally
but men only make up one percent
of sales men have been left out and now
they're being marketed to and with more
men at home
online and curious about self-care
brands are reaching out to them zanna
you brought up a point that really blew
my mind you know why because we're all
on zoom calls all day long and men
are now looking at themselves in the
little box on their call and like they
never would have before you don't walk
into a meeting with a mirror in front of
you now suddenly men are looking at
their reflection
all day long so well's new skincare line
it not only keeps your skin happy let's
drop that in
gq reports that human race line aims to
reduce plastic waste by using refillable
chambers made of recycled materials
now let's just talk about this packaging
shall we because
i am straight up componentry
envy i do i am i
i love milk's packaging i care very much
about flowers packaging where fanatics
about picking the vessels the components
creating stock
you know components creating custom this
guy he nails
everything i mean it is so beautiful so
vibrant it's refillable it's 50 post
consumer plastic so
instead of going to a landfill it's back
in a new product